marine le pen sarkozy hollande sont
finalement tous d'accord pour mener une
campagne sur le terrain du terrorisme de
l'immigration de l'identité nationale
c'est une campagne qui est démagogique
asseoir et là vous estimez collante
c'est la trahison de la maison tout ce
travail
regardez sarkozy va regarder les
programmes regarder comment ça se passe
en fait on a quoi on a séduction
élections trahison par est peut-être une
ministre de l'environnement heureuse
mais peut-être parce que vous n'avez pas
lu le livre de 800 est pas non plus une
interview même du saut dans paris match
cette semaine
qui dit que vous êtes réduite à
l'impuissance oui moi je réponds pas aux
attaques qui sont sans fondement tout ce
qui ne s'ancre pas dans la réalité est
vite emportés par les vents ici les gens
savent que quand le vent souffle on peut
partir loin donc moi je trace en effet
un sillon dans dans la durée lui dit il
faut que tu sois bien vu lui et il fera
révolue dit voulu conseillé d'être
candidat ce que je lui dis ça me regarde
oui mais et encore une fois c'est à lui
de se déterminer qui dit si j'y vais
c'est pour gagner ça veut dire que a
priori il n'ira pas s'ils pensent qu'il
ne gagnera pas ce que je pense qu'on
peut gagner pour te dis qu'il est pas
bon dans une démocratie même si chacun
est libre
qu'un ancien président de la république
revienne se représente pas ce que dans
aucune autre démocratie au montât ne se
passe comme ça on renouvelle les
générations qui la propose un programme
qui est une sorte de retour en arrière
c'est qui c'est le président sarkozy qui
veut en gros refaire ce qu'on a fait en
2007 il y avait des choses intelligentes
qu'elle est dans le bon sens mais qui
sont à mon avis absolument pas à la
hauteur de la difficulté que notre pays
rencontre et alain juppé qui considèrent
que en haletant que la france est un
pays fragile qu'il faut faire les choses
doucement une gauche et une droite qui
n'assument pas leurs convictions
un système politico rennes le
politiquement correct et par dessus tout
une base et me alone ou encore une
république de justice qui ouvre des
chances égales pour tous nous sommes
nous prêts pour les régressions les
reniements au nom d'une restauration
d'un ordre
chiens dans le bush la côte doit un peu
de centres très peu de scènes claude
fois in au dehors les colons sans saveur
à l'arrivée vous aurez d'extrême droite
et devant les yeux
voilà que jean françois copé vous êtes
le maire je dédie de la ville de meaux
les habitants les appels et les meldois
il ya eu aucun jumelage entre les
meldois et mon cul ya pas qu'à parler de
votre douceur aussi je tiens absolument
à garder cette séquence l'avantagent
séoul et via douceur c'est pas forcément
une île d yeu qualité principale si le
mec a été prospère bien sûr c'est
différent mais ça n'est pas forcément la
première comprennent pas ce que vous
cherchez
sauf que je suis fils de proctologue oil